welcome everyone to day 2 of our series
of three lectures by Professor Roger
Smith it's a high repeat audience so I
don't need to tell you how lucky we are
but I will say it again anyway to have
the distinguished scholar of American
politics and political thought Roger
Smith currently president of the
American Political Science Association
so we're especially grateful that he's
taking time from a very busy schedule I
think he committed to these talks before
the election so we're lucky that we we
locked him in so for those of you who
were here yesterday you know that he
began this inquiry into the debates
about identity and why these identities
are often in conflict and why populist
scan take advantage of these debates and
today I think it's going to be a kind of
turn for for a more positive story
perhaps and the title today is what
makes a good story and we know that
Roger Smith is one person who knows how
to do that so join me in welcoming
[Applause]
Thank You Francis today many scholars
pundits politicians and citizens in many
lands share deep worries about the
contemporary pathological forms of
populism I discussed yesterday
ideologies that valorize the people in
popular sovereignty but they do so in
ways that justify a liberal repression
and authoritarian rule many analysts are
advancing ideas about how best to
respond to these dangers just as I
agreed broadly with most of the
prevalent diagnosis of the economic and
cultural sources of current populism
I agree broadly with many recent
recommendations but even very valuable
suggestions are all too often wrapped in
highly abstract conceptions of
normatively desirable political
communities these abstract conceptions
tend to compete poorly with more
concrete and vivid
if often narrowly nationalistic populism
'z many scholars especially shy away
from the task of articulating
normatively desirable but also
distinctive stories of political people
hood for the societies in which populist
appeals hold increasing sway they do so
for understandable in some ways
commendable reasons nonetheless their
works still leave us groping for ways to
carry out the necessary intellectual and
political project of opposing bad
stories of political people hood with
better ones so in this lecture I'll lay
out some criteria for doing so let me
first summarize what I see as the arch
typical responses of most current
critics of populism to the dangers they
and I perceive this sketch doesn't fully
characterize anyone writers views but I
will cite prominent scholars whose
arguments closely approximated the
dominant remedies for pathological forms
of populism have three elements first
many argue that desirable national
identities must be fundamentally Civic
and liberal-democratic in nature resting
on an ideology championing
universalistic commitments to democracy
in human rights
rather than any blood and soil
conceptions of nationalism or of a
democracy's people second many suggests
that these desirable Liberal Democratic
national identities must somehow also
reflect the distinctive cultural
traditions prevalent in particular
societies the second response poses a
problem for the first how distinctive to
national identities be if all the
desirable ones rest on commitments to
the same universal principles of liberal
democracy most writers display some
awareness of this fundamental tension in
their arguments but few choose to
address it very explicitly or
elaborately third most critics of
populism instead primarily devote their
attention to reviewing the economic and
cultural grievances they see is driving
populist movements and then they offer a
list of economic and social policies to
address those grievances the economic
policies generally seek to promote
greater employment wages and benefits
while the social policies focus on
finding compromises with the opponents
of demographic diversity and especially
heightened immigration levels consider a
few recent examples in the people vs.
democracy why our freedom is in danger
and how to save it Jasha monk calls for
defenders of liberal democracy
everywhere to offer a positive message
to rival the narrative according to
which only a liberal populist can fix a
nation's problems this positive message
should be articulated he says in a new
language of inclusive patriotism that
builds on the tradition of multi-ethnic
democracy to show that the ties that
bind us go well beyond ethnicity and
religion these ties are instead he says
the basic tenets of liberal democracy
which should be rhetorically celebrated
inculcated through civic education and
strengthened by policies to realize them
more fully toward that in monk calls for
changes in tax and housing policies
education investments and a
restructuring of welfare states and work
to provide both greater economic
security and more meaningful employment
opportunities
he reluctantly calls for some
compromises with anti-immigration forces
but he cautions against jettison quote
the universal promises of liberal
democracy in favor of rights and duties
rooted in particular ethnic or religious
communities monks well-crafted arguments
conform fairly completely to the
three-part standard formula I've
sketched in regard to the core
difficulty of this formula however the
tension between the first position
favoring a universalistic ideological
conception of civic identity and the
second supporting development of a
distinctive national culture monks main
response is simply to admonish that the
second must not be allowed to erode the
first in ante pluralism the populist
threat to liberal democracy William
Galston adheres to the same basic
formula differing chiefly in some of his
policy recommendations he's clear from
the outset that his concern is with all
countries that base their identities on
civic commitments to liberal democracy
which he now says face deformations from
both elitist and anti pluralist populist
movements he calls on leaders in every
liberal democratic nation to combat
these deformations by articulating quote
the public culture of their community
its distinctive set of beliefs that
amalgamate principle shared history and
distinctive ethnicities their goal
should be to help the people to unite
around the fundamentals of their civic
identity Galston cites as examples the
deep patriotism of speeches by Martin
Luther King Franklin Roosevelt and
Ronald Reagan he also advocates for
economic policies designed to produce
full employment with rising wages and to
connect residents of small towns and
rural regions with the opportunities now
provided in cities and like monk Galston
calls for compromises with
anti-immigration forces in his case by
quote shifting away from family
reunification and toward economic
contribution as the main criterion for
emigration along with a greater focus on
helping immigrants learn English and a
working knowledge of American history
and civic institutions this is as far as
Galston goes however and clarifying how
he would deal with the tension between
the first and
second prongs of the standard response
to pathological populism
he doesn't seek to explain how leaders
can or should amalgamate principles of
liberal democracy with the distinctive
ethnicities and other particular
features of different nations that they
might they might well seem to contradict
finally in identity the demand for
dignity in the politics of resentment
Francis Fukuyama presents his version of
the same basic response he too contends
that we need creedal national identities
built around the foundational ideas of
modern liberal democracy Fukuyama adds
however a creedal identity is
unnecessary but not a sufficient
condition for success
it requires support from quote its own
culture which must be held in higher
esteem than cultures rejecting
democracy's values in this regard
Fukuyama refers to the importance of
stories of people hood suggesting a
progressive narrative can be told in
America at least about the overcoming of
barriers and ever broadening circles of
people whose dignity the country has
recognized based on its founding
principles he says nothing more however
about what creating and advancing such
narratives entails instead he repeatedly
stresses that the core task is to define
a proper creedal identity and he do too
devotes most of it his attention to
arguing for economic policies that can
mitigate concerns over jobs incomes and
security even as he urges compromises
with opponents of immigration he
particularly stresses sanctions against
employers of undocumented aliens and he
calls for public policies to
deliberately assimilate newcomers to
liberal cultural values through not just
civic education but also more demanding
naturalization tests and perhaps a
universal requirement for national
service like these authors I want to
find ways to strengthen the commitments
of political communities to democracy
and human rights and to advocate for
economic and social policies that help
realize these commitments in the lives
of people more fully and in ways that
respond to current popular grievances
even if I may not agree with all their
particular policies by focusing on what
makes a good story of people hood
I seek not so much to oppose as to add
to their broadly Kindred endeavors my
hope is that this focus can enable us to
find ways to address the tension between
civic identities based on universalistic
principles and the promotion of
distinctive inevitably more particular
political identities and cultures more
successfully than these standard
arguments do I should acknowledge
however that there are reasons to doubt
the route I am taking is open to us
David Ricci in particular is argued in
two books that modern liberalism as well
as positions further to the left
displays crippling but constitutive
features that partly explain the
difficulties of Liberal Democrats in
responding to exclusionary repressive
populism
he contends that unlike conservatives
liberals are often unwilling to tell and
may be unable to tell narratives of
national identity that responds
symbolically to popular desires for
feelings of secure belonging pride and
particular istic forms of solidarity and
the guide policies that help meet those
desires in practice precisely because
modern Liberal Democrats profess to
value cultural racial ethnic and
religious diversity and to respect
political and to rest political
legitimacy on conformity to principles
of democracy and human rights that they
deem universal many liberals are
uncomfortable with celebrations of the
histories and characteristics of a
nation's traditional dominant groups and
with measures designed to address their
concerns many see all particular istic
stories of national people hood as steps
on an all too logical slippery slope to
intolerant chauvinism most liberals also
esteem forms of scientific rationality
the challenge the myths and the
providential astir ease the national
narratives often espouse miss that now
sometimes extend to climate change
denial in their eyes to endorse most
national stories of people hood is to
pretend that preposterous
self-interested fables are true in fact
many liberals today see the whole world
system of sovereign independent nation
states as an archaic structure of
political and economic power and
institutions that inherent
breeds bigotry and indefensible
inequalities today's world of sovereign
nation-states must give way over time to
a more combat cosmopolitan and
Confederated forms of democracy if not
indeed a global Federal Republic I share
many of these concerns my own political
commitments arise most deeply from the
inspiration of the 1960s civil rights
and women's movements on the one hand
and from disillusionment with the
militarism and intolerance of the Cold
War and its consequences in Vietnam on
the other still embarrassing as it is to
confess the sight that most fired my
teenage political imagination occurred
in 1966 when I first laid eyes on the
bridge of the Starship Enterprise as it
appeared in the first season of Star
Trek the crew on that bridge were
officers of an amazing interstellar
Federal Republic the United Federation
of Planets
they included individuals from America's
World War two enemy Japan its Cold War
rivalry shaaa an african-american woman
and even a true alien a Vulcan who
looked a bit sinister but who presumably
was documented of course setting
reassuring boundaries to all this
radicalism the captain was a swaggering
white man from Iowa and he and the
ship's chief engineer and doctor were
all of at least partly Scottish descent
corneas all this sounds now in 1966 the
sight of these diverse people working
together as equals on missions of
scientific exploration launched by the
most cosmopolitan Federal Republic
imaginable seemed a path-breaking vision
of a future that might realize the best
of Enlightenment ideals the truth is I
would still love to take that journey
but as the recent surge of exclusionary
repressive nationalistic movements shows
we are a long way away from doing so
moreover liberal discourses that naive
presume this vision is obviously the
normatively right one for Humanity as I
once did can be active impediments to
moving in this direction Ricci is right
that the rhetoric of these discourses
often fails to appeal effectively to
people in groups who feel harmed by
economic globalization in cosmopolitan
multiculturalism and who hold more
traditionalist views including many
conventional forms of religion and
patriotism
indeed liberal radix rhetorics often
convey disdain for such groups and their
beliefs in values fostering
understandable resentments yet though
differences and disagreements are
inevitable there's no reason to conclude
that the causes of democracy human
rights and human progress must be
articulated in such counterproductive
ways there's no reason to conclude that
liberals cannot tell compelling
political stories even though it is true
that they are now often failing to do so
if Liberal Democrats believe that people
have rights to the pursuit of happiness
for example and many persons prefer to
pursue happiness through the shared
lives of political communities with
distinctive identities and traditions
then it is not only appropriate it is
mandatory to give considerable deference
to their choices we will then be in a
position to join with them to advance
desirable values partly through the aid
of good stories of their preferred forms
of peoplehood stories can provide this
aid because it's natural for stories to
incorporate current political grievances
and challenges as well as deeply valued
senses of identity and affiliation into
broader accounts of both the past and
possible futures most importantly as
you've all her Ahri's argument
concerning the sources of large-scale
human collective actions indicates
stories can make memberships in
particular political communities not
only appear to be but actually be
distinctive collective endeavors that
their participants can hope to make more
broadly and deeply beneficial over time
instead of depicting political
membership as a matter of pledging
allegiance to an abstract Civic creed
and especially a creed that mandates
duties that many gloomily feel they
cannot fulfill stories of people who
can portray memberships in ways that
foster a different political psychology
they can encourage us to think of
ourselves as doing what we must do to
carry on our distinctive Colada
collective political projects today even
as they give us reason to feel that we
may be able to do still better tomorrow
they can't enable us to say to
proponents of cruelty that is not who we
are
still more importantly they can help us
depict and decide who we want to be and
how we can become the best that we can
be if that is they are good stories of
people hood what makes such stories good
or at least better than other stories by
good stories of people hood I mean two
things
stories that do a good job empirically
of engaging and inspiring people and
stories that conveys substantive
messages that we can defend as
normatively commendable it is only
stories of people hood that are good in
both these senses that provide a
promising means to ease the tension
between trying to foster commitments to
overarching if perhaps not truly
universal principles of democracy and
rights while also advancing compelling
themes about the significance of
membership in particular forms of
political community insisting that
stories must be good according to norms
of democracy and human rights may
however appear only to reproduce the
standard formula I've sketched instead
of improving it it may sound like good
stories of people hood must all be
variants of the same fundamentally
liberal democratic Creed grounded on
commitments to abstract moral principles
but this criticism relies on an
understanding of principles of democracy
and human rights as fundamentally moral
conclusions reached through detached
philosophic reasoning of you I do not
take my argument is instead in the vein
of Michael walzer's conception of
political philosophy as at its most most
truthful connected social criticism an
effort to interpret the experiences
identities and moral values we find in
our social worlds and then reason on the
basis of the most persuasive
understandings of them we can reach
those understandings may or may not
eventually take the form of appeal to
what we regard as universal principles
of Reason or perhaps divine revelation
those principles or revelations are not
the starting point
however for treating the values in
particular social realms as concerns we
should take seriously beginning instead
with the moral traditions prevalent in
actual social realms what I contend is
this if we seek to develop stories of
people hood that are empirically
effective and normatively desirable then
most in most of the world we will find
that connected critical engagement with
people's experiences and values will not
only enable us to do so such engagement
will generally prompt us to elaborate
stories in which concerns for democracy
human dignity and some forms of human
rights have prominent places the logic
of seeking through connected critical
engagement to develop good political
stories in and for different communities
in the world today points to three
deeply interrelated criteria that should
guide these endeavors call them the 3
R's of writing good people hood stories
stories must be resonant respectful and
reticulated yes I admit I'm reaching a
bit to get to that third arm but it's
perhaps the most important one to
highlight at this point in global
history first resident just as Walters
connected social critic must do stories
of people hood must speak to and from
the conceptions of identities and
interests that the audiences whom the
stories address already possess even
when political storytellers seek to
convince people to Rican sieve those
identities and interest in some ways as
they inevitably do the stories must find
a persuasive place for the economic and
cultural anxieties and difficulties
people are experiencing
they must also articulate community
goals and promising policies in which
people can see at least some of their
most cherished values advanced as
alinsky organizers have long preached to
be effective would be political and
intellectual leaders must begin by
taking people where they are where they
cannot expect a good reception this
criterion of resonance means that
composing good stories of people hood
requires a rich knowledge of particular
political context
the traditions values pre-existing
identities and practices that the
inhabitants of particular areas possess
as well as the challenges they face
again it is with textured understanding
of the norms identities and concerns
imminent within the specific context not
abstract reasoning the composition of
stories of people who'd must start even
if we choose to elaborate them in ways
that may eventually propel people well
beyond existing community arrangements
and boundaries this criterion assures
that stories of people hood will be
significantly different for different
populations in different places for they
will always have varying pre-existing
identities histories and problems yet
resonance is not just necessary for
stories of people who had to be good
stories in the sense of being
empirically effective in gaining
acceptance less obviously but equally
importantly resonance must be sought if
stories of people who are to be good
normatively this is so because
normatively desirable stories must also
conform to the second R which requires
that stories be respectful what does the
second criterion entail who must stories
of people hood respect how and why the
answers to these questions have always
been highly contested still in the 21st
century these contests take place on
material and moral planes with different
horizons than those that prevailed in
many parts of the world in the past it
makes a great difference that most
people today have far more access and
more rapid access to news and stories
about people elsewhere that they did
throughout most of human history at this
point few if any can escape having some
awareness of religious philosophical
moral legal and political traditions
assigning inestimable value to the
dignity of every human being most
instead identify with at least some of
these traditions frequently their
governments are signatories to
international treaties that commit them
to respect for human rights and
democratic self-governance journalists
advocacy groups and sometimes other
states can and do bring pressure to live
up to these commitments as a result in
virtually every context today it is
always possible indeed it's often
able to find that many local values and
experiences give strong reasons for
insisting that states should act with
respect for all human beings
it is often though not always even
easier to insist that states should
respect all those people over whom they
assert the right and power to govern in
almost every context moreover most agree
that respect requires first giving some
minimal hearing to people's voices to
their concerns hopes and fears it's
impossible to claim to respect those to
whom one refuses ever to listen respect
means second engaging with people in a
spirit of accommodation whenever
possible it means accepting that others
are entitled to pursue their preferred
ways of life unless we feel we must
judge their ways illegitimate or harmful
now that unless is to be sure a major
qualification of what respect requires
in some communities pursuits and
practices that other communities permit
or even valorize such as cross ethnic
marriages are widely deemed repugnant
many in the first camp see the more
permissive communities as to foreign and
other to merit respect virtually every
community also displays intense internal
disagreements over the legitimacy of
some members preferred pursuits making
respect for all within the community
hard to sustain yet it remains true that
we can find almost everywhere values and
traditions arguing that even if certain
pursuits and the people pursuing them
are ultimately to be condemned
still all persons and certainly persons
the government's are seeking to govern
initially deserve to receive basic
respect consequently those narrating
stories of people hood acting as
connected critics can virtually always
tell stories that respect the dignity
and attend to the values and concerns of
all whom they're likely to affect in
ways that resonate with moral
commitments their audiences can see as
their own precisely because the second
criterion calls for narratives that
express respect and open us to
accommodations for the diverse ways of
life pursued by individuals and
communities who are included in
particular stories of people hood it
leads in turn to the third criterion for
those stories to be deemed good
they must be reticulated stories
narratives that openly embrace a
significant measure of pluralism within
the shared life of the society whose
stories they tell
reticulated as a term for networks that
display discernible patterns good
stories of people hood should help weave
networks with two kinds of discernible
patterns one internal to the stories one
more external internally in accordance
with the criterion of respect narratives
should not demand Civic uniformity
instead they should authorize
accommodations of a people subgroups
such as minority religions geographic
regions indigenous communities and more
to the greatest degree possible
consistent with the constitutive themes
that are central in that particular
account of people hood these
accommodations can take many forms
including federalism special
representation and legislatures
exemptions from some generally binding
laws and others externally stories
should convey openness to compromising
with and often joining with the policies
and institutions advanced by advocates
of distinct but overlapping stories of
people hood whenever they have common
ground they should express recognition
that their society's actual institutions
and policies are far more likely to be a
network of shifting patterns emerging
from evolving areas of agreement among
many stories rather than the hegemony of
anyone in light of the great diversity
president in most if not all modern
societies good stories of people hood
must be reticulated stories in both
these ways if they are to resonate
broadly and if they are to express
respect for all they wish to include in
their conception of We the People
now many will find the argument thus far
too optimistic some might insist that
these three criteria display the same
kind of internal tension if not
contradiction that I identified in the
standard formula for responding to
pathological populism
even if some commitments to democracy
and human rights are present in most
places so the critique might go often
they will not be enough to sustain this
endeavor in many places if we really try
to compose stories of people hood that
resonate with the traditions and
identities that are locally prevalent we
simply won't end up with narratives that
incorporate respect for all or
willingness to provide diverse groups
many forms of accommodation perhaps so
but we should not presume that this is
true nor should we set the bar too high
for when we can advise advancing such
inclusive stories worth while it is not
my claim that anywhere and everywhere we
can always find ways of composing and
advancing resonant respectful
reticulated stories of people hood that
are sure to defeat all opponents
including champions of anti pluralist
authoritarian forms of populism nothing
is certain in politics it is my claim
however that we can see in every context
the potential for stories of this sort
to be serious political competitors in
the remainder of this lecture I seek to
make this claim plausible by noting the
potential for better stories of people
hood in a few of the countries around
the world where pathological forms of
populism are powerful today but I am NOT
a deeply connected social critic of any
of these countries so I can only discuss
them sensitively in the hopes that
others more engaged with these societies
will be able to work out how to do
better yet in the final lecture I will
offer a more developed argument about
how we can and must tell better stories
of people hood now in America in this my
own my native land for now let's
consider Denmark a nation that regularly
scores at or near the top of the world's
rankings for a happiest country on earth
yet happy as they may be over all the
Danes have over the last decade and a
half given increasing support to an
anti-immigration self-proclaimed
populist party the Danish People's Party
since 2015 it has been the second
largest party in the Danish Parliament
and it's calls for restrictive
immigration and naturalization policies
as well as civic education systems
fostering Danish culture more actively
have shifted the positions and policies
of other Danish parties in the DPP's
preferred directions the party's leaders
to pick these positions as the latest
episode in a long and stirring story of
the Danes struggles to maintain their
identity as one has put it
Denmark has a more than a thousand year
history based on the Danish peoples
ongoing battle to exist in spite of
unfavorable Geographic and strategic
circumstances the Danish People's Party
is a more successful offshoot of the
older economically focused anti-tax and
anti government spending progress party
from its start the DPP has stood on a
platform whose essence party leader
Kristian - listen doll has stated is
quote a warm and strong love of our
country its manifesto contains economic
and political power themes but it
focuses on constitutive values of our
Danish cultural heritage which must be
preserved and strengthened it defines
that culture as the sum of the danish
people's history experience beliefs
language and customs among those customs
the Danish People's Party stresses
Denmark's constitutional monarchy as
part of the nation's system of
representative government and the Danish
Evangelical Lutheran Church which the
party wants the government to support
without prejudicing ordinary religious
freedom in its terms the party also
greatly emphasizes the importance of
maintaining Denmark's sovereignty it
opposes the European Union though not
NATO as a threat to that sovereignty and
it is steadfastly against large-scale
immigration insisting it will not accept
transformation to a multi-ethnic society
unlike its predecessor the Progress
Party however the Danish People's Party
is not opposed to Denmark's extensive
social welfare state funded through
income taxes that have averaged over 60%
during the last quarter century the
party accepts health care as a public
responsibility and it endorses a public
education system if combined with free
choice between state and private schools
unlike many conservative populist
parties it calls for taking care of the
natural world so that future generations
can live in a clean and healthy
environment it promises to play an
active role in representative government
working more than happily in cooperation
with other parties so that our country
and its democracy may evolve freely it
pledges its support for the fundamental
liberties of speech the right of
assembly and religious liberty as well
as the Danish state community the
vestige of dinner
ARC's former Empire that Accords a
significant measure of autonomous home
rule to Greenland and the Faroe Islands
the Danish People's Party then
explicitly advances a story of Danish
people hood that embraces economic
themes that would sound social
democratic in the United States its
political power themes stress both
active participation in representative
democratic institutions at the national
and local levels cooperation with the
poor a latina parties with other views
whenever possible and even a reticulated
recognition of special statuses for the
Greenland and Ferraris peoples it also
promises support for a range of
individual rights rather than seeking to
become an authoritarian populist
dictator its longtime leader Christian
to listen doll has repeatedly chosen not
to pursue becoming Prime Minister the
party's right-wing character arise
chiefly in its cultural themes which are
to be sure its signature themes its
calls for restrictive immigration and
demanding naturalization policies with
particular option to Muslim immigrants
it's a version of multiculturalism or
multi ethnicity more generally and its
emphasis on supporting the national
Christian Church and monarchy the appeal
of these positions is all too
understandable however in light of
Danish history and particularly the
challenges to modern Denmark posed by
membership in the European Union and
broader forces of economic and cultural
globalization and immigration an
influential 19th century version of
Danish Danish history identified with an
enormous Lee popular book by historian
CF Allen presented the Danes as an
ancient culturally homogeneous and
democratic peasant people who suffered
through the centuries from the emergence
of a repressive nobility foreign
religious influences and periods of
foreign rule then the creation of a
constitutional monarchy with a
representative Parliament and a national
Christian Church restored democracy
national sovereignty and cultural unity
this is essentially the story the Danish
People's Party tells today modern
writers have shown however the Denmark
was in fact a conglomerate multinational
multilingual monarchy up until its 1864
defeat by Prussia which led to its loss
of schleswig-holstein and
berg and a new period of nation-state
building subsequently a peasant movement
successfully sought to strengthen Danish
agriculture through the creation of
cooperatives to which virtually all
Danish farmers still belong this
agricultural movement allow allied in
the late 19th century with an
educational movement led by Nikolai FS
groom fig who fostered the creation of
people's high schools to inculcate an
egalitarian sense of Danish people hood
workers movements also gave rise to the
Danish Social Democrats who came to
present socialism as an expression of
the Solidarity that should characterize
the Danish nation-state the Danish
peasant and worker movements often at
odds eventually came together after
World War Two in support of the high tax
high social provision Danish welfare
state at that point the cultural scholar
ova course card argues welfare and
Danish nice B came one in the same to be
Danish was and still is to identify
oneself with the Danish welfare project
however course guard and others contend
subsequent developments have since
besieged proponents of this sense of
Danish people hood the Danes decision to
join the European Economic Community and
then the European Union while retaining
their own currency have raised questions
about the relationship of Danish people
hood to European identity EU policies
have also facilitated immigration into
Denmark including some Muslims
immigrants of all sorts are now just
under 9% of the Danish population and
workforce though this amount is not huge
it is sufficient to shake the strong
sense of cultural solidarity and
economic partnership that is underpin
Danish willingness in the modern era to
accept high taxes in return for
extensive social welfare benefits now
newcomers who have not long paid into
the tax system and who may not share the
feelings of solidarity that create trust
that all will do their part seem to be
demanding equal treatment with those who
have long been partners in that Danish
welfare project beyond these concerns
some feel that is a small nation within
the EU and other regional and global
institutions in which participation
requires that they learn English because
the world will never learn Danish
days sometimes feel they're in real
danger of having their distinctive
national cultural identity entirely
eclipsed within one or two generations
hence the constitutive themes the Danish
People's Party story of Danish people
hood are potent the cultural anxieties
and fears of economic burdens and
political insignificant that the DPP's
story addresses all richly merited
attention still the Danish People's
Party manifesto itself shows that values
of democracy human rights even a measure
of autonomous self-governance for some
distinct communities also all have great
resonance in Denmark today even if it is
a myth that ancient Danes comprised a
Democratic peasant nation it's not a
myth that many Danes have long valued
stories of themselves as a deeply
Democratic people furthermore Denmark
has an older history of being a
multi-ethnic multilingual society that
some writers suggests deserves
recognition as a proud heritage and a
source of guidance sustained seek to
cope with greater emigration today
this heritage suggests that Danes have
shown historically that they can find
ways to embrace diversity and still
flourish and if as sociologist Richard
Jenkins suggests modern Danes
particularly value as symbols of their
peoplehood the national flag the
Dannebrog their constitutional monarchy
and the Danish language it doesn't seem
impossible for more liberal Danes to
advance an egalitarian and inclusive
story of people hood in which all these
treasured elements have a secure place
if that seems too sanguine note that the
core cultural value that Groot vidiians
taught in the people's high schools was
folk lling defined as tolerance openness
liberal mindedness the means to achieve
folk league his enlightenment and
committed dialogue aimed at consensus
according to historian cloths molar
Jorgenson it doesn't seem far-fetched to
say then that as the Danish People's
Party pushes immigration concerns to the
point of ugly anti-muslim bigotry
visible in recent measures to ban the
burqa and niqab to mark out ghetto areas
and to require naturalized citizens to
shake the hands of their mayor's other
Danes can push back and say that is not
who we are perhaps they can tell a
contrasting story depict
Danish people hood as devoted to a
distinctive yet exemplary democratic
social welfare project characterized by
full again openness and tolerance this
story should include policies to ensure
that all who benefit from that project
really contribute to it but it's likely
that most immigrants will take pride in
doing so though there are no guarantees
of success it's not hopeless to try
after all despite everything most Danes
are still very happy let us next
consider is still more challenging case
India the world's largest constitutional
democracy since its post-colonial
founding in 1947 up through the 1980s
the Congress party of Nehru and the
Gandhi's dominated Indian elections but
Congress party preeminence then waned in
the Bharatiya Janata Party or BJP
generally termed a right-leaning hindu
nationalist party gained increased
support in 2014 under the leadership of
Narendra Modi the BJP at last won a
governing majority in India's Parliament
as well as control of many state
governments it has shaped India's course
since then the election manifesto that
helped bring the baiji BJP to power lays
out a forceful story of Indian people
hood contending that to build a modern
India the best foundation is our own
culture saying that the BJP recognises
that no nation could chart out its
policies unless it has a clear
understanding about itself its history
its roots its strengths and failings the
manifestos preface written by Manohar
Joshi identifies many strengths it
proclaims quote India is the most
ancient civilization of the world and it
has always been looked upon by the world
as a land of wealth and wisdom before
the advent of the British errs it
asserts India had a much bigger role in
presence in industry in manufacturing
than any nation in Europe and Asia in
those days I quote India was a land of
abundance prosperity affluence a land of
sharing and caring living in perfect
harmony and peace with nature from
ancient times almost all religions
practiced in different parts of the
world have existed peacefully in India
and will continue
do so India thus provides the most
ennobling experience in spiritual
coexistence eventually the oppressive
British did come as in fact the Muslim
Mughal Emperors had before them against
the British Joshi wrote the leaders of
the Indian freedom struggle kept the
Indian ways and thoughts in the centre
of their action they had a vision to
reconstruct the political and economic
institutions of India as a continuum of
civilizational consciousness which made
India one country one people and one
nation but after independence he says
the leaders at the helm of affairs lost
the spirit in the vision and adopted the
institutional framework created by the
British errs which was quite alien to
India's worldview doing so produced a
multi-dimensional crisis that crisis
included rising disparities social and
communal divide and terrorism leading to
a fractured society but at its heart
joshi said was concentration of power in
a few hands and lack of people's
participation producing corruption and
nepotism on a massive scale for India to
progress Joshi contended Indians must
arrive at a consensus about the idea of
India recognize the power of its world
view and redesign our approach in
consonance with the Preferences of the
Indian people
the manifesto therefore stresses that
India is a democracy and the BJP has
often treated it as a majoritarian
democracy in which the preferred world
view of its super majority of Hindus
should prevail still the manifesto
recognized India as a diverse country in
which different communities settled in
vastly different regions have their own
aspirations it promised a highly
decentralized federal structure that
would recognise the special needs and
unique status of different regions and
territories but it stated all this
should happen within the framework of
our Constitution and with the spirit of
India first any activity which disrupts
the integrity of the nation cannot be in
the interest of any segment of the
society or any region of the country
insisting that the BJP recognizes the
importance of diversity in Indian
society it explained the party believes
in the principle of unity in diversity
it maintained this vision of India
extended to all ethnic social and
cultural groups including the Muslim
community
now stymied in poverty it said because
our culture is defined by tolerance and
coexistence the only philosophy and
religion of a government it concluded
should be India first much of the rest
of the document features proposals for
sweeping improvements in democratic
processes and governmental
administration as well as economic and
educational betterment
the Indian story of peoplehood is told
in the BJP s 2014 manifesto thus
celebrates participatory democracy it
advocates for reticulated federal
governance it also commits not just to
respect for all communities but also to
contribute to their progress these
promises are in tension
however with Manohar Joshi she's done CA
ssin of inferior alien institutions in
favor of India's ancient civilization
akanchha sness it's also unclear how
much diversity can really consist with
putting India first it's noteworthy that
Joshi once faced prosecution for saying
that if his party won a state election
it would create the first Hindu state
the Indian Supreme Court eventually held
this to be permissible political
expression so he wasn't punished it's
also noteworthy however that Modi
himself campaigned in 2014 primarily on
issues of economic development and an
end to corruption with less emphasis on
Hindu nationalism than he had
articulated in the past still other BJP
leaders have not been so reticent before
or since then once in power the BJP has
banned cow slaughter for consumption a
policy that many see is responsible for
an uprising and Muslim lynchings it's
appointed an outspoken Hindu nationalist
monk yogi Adityanath as chief minister
in India's largest state who dar pradesh
and its authorized police measures
officially to protect women that have
permitted the frequent exercise of force
against muslim men despite the BJP s
proclamations of respect for all
religions that's it Jana has castigated
mother Teresa for seeking to
Christianize India amongst other
provocative statements and actions
French political scientist Christophe
Shah Furlow argues that under this sort
of BJP leadership India's on the path to
becoming an ethnic democracy one that is
majoritarian but not in what he calls
the classic sense of the word liberal
other observers believe that only the
in judiciary and the Election Commission
of India can check India's continued
majoritarian drift toward religious
politics and many despair of either
institution doing so these analyses
raise doubts about whether better
stories of Indian people hood can serve
to curb the dangers of Hindu nationalist
populism still the 2014 BJ platform
professed no national religion other
than India first Modi most champion
economic and infrastructure growth while
he criticized the anti-democratic
continuation of traditional cast
advantages and the accompanying
pervasive corruption that the Congress
party despite its similar rhetoric had
never eradicated the BJP won in 2014 by
turning out large numbers of new voters
especially in urban areas who were Hindu
but also disengaged from a political
system they saw as closed and
indifferent to them in states where
existing Chief Minister's were governing
more effectively incumbents retained
strong electoral support because just
under 80 percent of Indians identify as
Hindu it is immediately hard to
disentangle majoritarianism from support
from the idea of India as a Hindu nation
but it is not clear that most Indians
have ever embraced a hard Hindu
nationalist view of Indian identity
instead the BJP zone manifesto confirms
that much in Indian traditions and
experiences provides ingredients for
very different and more inclusive
stories of Indian people hood as the
distinguished political scientists Anil
Kanani affirmed those situated at
different locations in India society had
produced their own distinctive
conceptions of the nation until the
British subjected the peoples of the
subcontinent to British rule in British
labeling many diverse communities there
did not even consider themselves Indian
though many did share narrative
structures embodied in epics myths and
folk stories as well as caste structures
kill Lonnie says when they opposed
British accounts of Indian identity
relying on their own stories they
provided materials for many rival
accounts of who is an Indian virtually
all those stories however valorize India
as a democracy
kill nani himself advanced a grand
narrative in which independent
India appears as the third moment in the
great democratic experiment launched by
the American and French Revolutions the
key disputes have been over what sort of
democracy is appropriate in light of
India's extraordinary diversity Mahatma
Gandhi urged embrace of a wide variety
of religious traditions local beliefs
and identities within a shared cultural
consciousness and he portrayed India as
a nation of diverse self-sustaining
Democratic villages but is highly
spiritual as strongly anti status vision
lost influence after independence
nonetheless evocations of an Indian
prehistory of tolerant village
Republic's as the authentic roots of
Indian democracy persist to this day
Jawaharlal Nehru however favored a
strong Democratic central state that
would protect Indians cultural and
religious diversity by recognizing
interconnected differences eventually
including language based States all
united behind central governmental
initiatives for economic progress the
great delete' leader BR Ambedkar
influenced in part by his Columbia
University mentor John Dewey sought to
promote a Democratic Society of fluid
memberships and mobility but he believed
in India this required a constitutional
system guaranteeing distinctive economic
educational and political opportunities
for disadvantaged groups under his
influence India's Constitution and later
policies created sets of group rights
that generated material benefits and
senses of membership in the state's
Democratic project but these measures
also foster sharply conflicting
political identities movements and
parties as the Congress party faltered
amid rising senses of division and
fragmentation many came to see Modi the
BJP and Hindu nationalism as the best
available option nonetheless the
nationalist Hindutva vision remains
intensely controversial
in current debates on the idea of India
many voices invoke the founding idea of
India as a secular pluralistic and
multicultural entity all this wrapped in
the idea of democracy whether they
appeal to the Constitution's recognition
of diversity to Gandhi's diverse
Democratic villages or even to the BJP
zone narrative of
as providing the most ennobling
experience in spiritual coexistence
conceptions of India as a more
pluralistic indeed reticulated democracy
than is provided by simple majority rien
ISM appeared to retain great resonance
consequently they there may well be real
potential for a variety of stories that
address economic and corruption concerns
and persuasively narrate India as a
great modern democracy whose distinctive
culture enables it to progress while
accommodating indeed celebrating vast
diversity if these stories contend that
India's special traditions and
experiences actually make it the best of
the great modern democratic nations at
least potentially this still may be an
idea of India well worth advancing with
trepidation I turn to one last example
Israel if you even whisper that word
many judge everything you say by what
you have said about Israel it also is
not clear whether Israel's governing
coalition is part of the current surge
of right-wing nationalist populism in
many countries however recent events
have made Israel's such a perfect
example of contrasting narratives of
peoplehood that it would be wrong to
ignore it as morale Virgen are and I
have argued many authoritative Israeli
sources have told the story of Israeli
people hood as governed by an enduring
law or mechanism which we summed up as
when Jews have a state of their own in
the homeland of Israel they prosper when
they do not have that state they suffer
the 1948 declaration of the
establishment of the State of Israel for
example depicted the Land of Israel as
the original home of the Jewish people
where they created cultural values of
national and universal significance
prior to being forcibly exiled from
their land after that Jews in every
successive generation sought to return
home unless they until they were at last
able to do so after the horrors of the
Holocaust the Declaration and other
founding documents of Israel famously
presented it as both a Jewish and a
democratic state creating tensions and
aspirations that have been central
features of Israeli life ever since the
declaration also made prominent
commitments to respect the basic rights
and liberties of all
said that Israel quote will foster the
development of the country for the
benefit of all its inhabitants and will
ensure complete equality of social and
political rights to all its inhabitants
irrespective of religion race or sex
providing freedom of religion conscience
language education and culture it called
for the Arab inhabitants of the State of
Israel to preserve peace and participate
in the up building of the state on the
basis of full and equal citizenship even
as it referred to the sovereign Jewish
people now settled in its own land
though much has happened since 1948 the
issues concerning whether Israel can
truly be a Jewish state and a democracy
that accords full and equal citizenship
in a wide range of rights to its Arab
inhabitants have only grown more acute
on July 19 2018 the Knesset approved a
new basic law defining Israel as the
nation-state of the Jewish people it
reasserted that the Land of Israel is
the national home of the Jewish people
where the State of Israel fulfills that
people's quote natural cultural
religious and historical right to
self-determination this basic law
specifies that the right to national
self-determination in the State of
Israel is unique to the Jewish people
it says the state's language is Hebrew
though the Arabic language has a special
status in the state non-jews also have a
right to maintain days of rest on their
Sabbath's and festivals the new basic
law does not however repeat the promises
of complete equality of social and
political rights and full and equal
citizenship for Arab inhabitants in the
1948 declaration it therefore triggered
many debates including a striking one on
the op-ed pages of the New York Times on
August 14 2018 Ronald s louder president
of the World Jewish Congress published a
column criticizing the new law entitled
Israel this is not who we are
router's said the nation state law which
correctly reaffirms that Israel is a
Jewish state damages the sense of
equality and belonging of Israel's Druze
Christian and Muslim citizens telling
his own story of Jewish peoplehood
louder argued quote for four thousand
years the Jewish people were seen as the
world's moral compass the Zionist
movement has been unwaveringly
democratic from its very
our writ large upon its flag were
liberty equality and human rights for
all and Israel's founding declaration
louder noted as I just did guaranteed
equality of social and political rights
as well as freedoms of religion language
and culture he maintained Theodor Herzl
Khayyam Weissman Ze'ev Jabotinsky David
ben-gurion and Golda Meir always
emphasized the need to combine Jewish
nationalism with universal humanism he
insisted that for over 200 years modern
Judaism has aligned itself with
enlightenment fusing national pride in
religious affiliation with a dedication
to human progress worldly culture and
morality he saw the new basic law and
the current Israeli government is acting
to quote crush the core of contemporary
Jewish existence louder concluded this
is not who we are and this is not who we
wish to be and he called for efforts to
ensure that Israel will continue to be
the Jewish Democratic state it is meant
to be Naftali Bennett Israel's Minister
of Education quickly fired off a
response entitled Israel is proud of who
we are he contended the new basic law
passed only after decades of successive
rulings by Israel's judiciary have
ignored the aspirations of those who
seek to preserve the Jewish nature of
our state the Israeli Supreme Court's
interpretations of another basic law
entitled human dignity and liberty in
cases involving immigration in the
extension of Israeli citizenship to
Palestinians amounted he said to a
direct attack on Israel's Jewish
character then it praised the
government's effort to ensure equality
and education academia and employment
for Israel's Arab communities and he
insisted that Israel's other basic laws
reinforce the freedom of expression and
equality for all citizens of Israel he
conceded that the Druze of Israel were
right to point out their special
relationship with the Jewish state was
not affirmed in the new nation state law
and he thought that should be rectified
by means other than changing the law
past it needed to stand to keep Israel
as the Jewish nation state now from a
liberal standpoint Bennett's claim that
equal citizenship for Arab Israelis is
protected by the state's other base
laws even as he was attacking the
Israeli Supreme Court's rulings based on
the basic law of human dignity and
liberty was not persuasive from a
conservative standpoint louder's claimed
that Israel's identity as a Jewish state
was threatened by a law reaffirming just
that was even less convincing my aim
here is not to arbitrate this debate
rather I wish to highlight it as an
example of how those who see themselves
as proponents of universal values of
democracy and human rights as louder
does can tell a deeply contextual
particular story of how their
community's heritage ethos and spirit is
historical achievements and it's modern
commitments all call for respecting and
advancing those values it's also
significant the louder is an American
who leads an international advocacy
organization for Jewish communities the
fact that he criticized Israel's new law
in new york times and that Education
Minister benefit Bennett felt compelled
to respond immediately shows how
national efforts to define peoplehood
today often face challenges from groups
and movements beyond their borders that
they do not feel they can ignore I
believe that in many places today those
kinds of challenges can be much more
persuasive when connected criticism and
advocacy inform compelling stories of
distinctive people hood of the kind that
Ronald louder advanced more persuasive
does not mean always victorious it is
highly unlikely that Israel will change
its new national law or any of the other
recent measures that louder faulted
anytime soon yet even if we cannot know
whether telling particular istic stories
of political people hood that contain
with it within them affirmations for
inclusive egalitarian measures will
succeed politically it's hard to see how
in the present moment major successes
can be won without them so in the final
lecture I will try to show how we can
tell better stories of American people
hood than the ones that are loudest
today
[Applause]
overwhelming agreement so your argument
comes in you need to tell a partly
alternate story that calls for greater
inclusion and more egalitarian policies
but you also want to emphasize the fact
that your story does have elements in
common there are aspects of the Danish
People's Party manifesto of the BJP
manifesto that you can endorse and so
you find some common ground while also
pushing back against some positions
that's what I mean by engagement it's a
critical engagement
you can follow up on that in some way
I'm wondering who you think should
develop these stories because it seems
like there's there's an incitement to be
a connected critic but but what is the
process of developing these stories
since many of those you might think
about are sort of elite driven or sort
of top-down but what's the role of sort
of democratic storytelling
well my picture of this process is one
that involves both elite and non elite
contributions and the non elite
contributions off which can come through
a whole variety of artistic or social or
community endeavors in which people
articulate their sense of their
community's story these help shape an
environment of ideas that elites leaders
inevitably must draw on and partly
reflect and respond even as they do some
reshaping to advance their own visions
and purposes I do think that it is
people in power who most directly and
people who are competing to get power
who most directly advance these kinds of
stories of people hood but they don't
write on a blank slate they write amidst
a broader cultural world in which many
voices have contributed to those stories
and that constrains what they can hope
to do effectively so both are involved
yeah do you have some good examples
cases where this has been done
successfully
I think there are examples where it's
been done successfully but there's no
examples of permanent success because
politics is a contingent contested
process it swings in different ways I
will argue for example tomorrow that
Barack Obama told a different story of
American people hood than George W Bush
I won't go into Bush's story tomorrow
although I have in other writings but so
I'll say now that george w bush told a
very providential a story of American
people hood his first inaugural address
ends that quoting Jefferson that and
saying what he begins by describing the
story of the American people and then he
says we are not the authors of this
story
an angel sits in the whirlwind and rides
the storm and his rhetoric written by
Michael Gerson his deeply religious
speechwriter frequently uses Provident
prosit Protestant providential 'lest
imagery to suggest an American mission
to fulfill God's plan for the world
Barack Obama told a different and in my
view more inclusive story that I will
talk about tomorrow about how the
American mission is a pluralist unum
creating unity without a facing
diversity that that's our fundamental
commitment and that's story one to
presidential elections it then gave way
to a very different story so there are
examples of success yes but at the same
time permanent success is not something
we expect in politics
Shayla thanks Roger always to have
pleasure to listen to you but I'm going
to push back a little bit you expected a
corner okay two points the first is that
I really very much doubt that telling
different stories of people hood and I
liked those stories and I sympathize
with them and if I were running for
offices that there are other tell their
stories but I also I really don't think
that they're going to face the populace
challenge we get to two examples then
mark I visited one son Israel I visited
many times the days like most Europeans
want to have their cake and eat it too
okay it's a it's a small country and it
maintains that welfare state also
because it is integrated into the
European Union market although they
don't use the European currency and is
very confusing to just lock travel
forty-five minutes and then you will end
up with a different bunch of money but
they have benefited their farmers have
benefited their businesses have
benefited precisely also because it is
so close to the angular market so they
want to have their cake and but now some
of the migration the nine percent that
you mentioned is internal European
migration a lot of poles for example
right ok all over and then of course the
comes the story about you know the
Muslim immigrants and this kind of
fundamentalist liberalism which sounds
like a moronic work but the Danes have
been active since the Mohammed
caricature controversy and there is
something going
on there that I think one should be
deeper into rather than you know I think
you underestimate whatever it is that
this particular item they're both in
terms of self-interest and secondly in
terms of the kind of fundamentals fervor
with which they believe in their
liberalism or the Netherlands for
example I'm not quite sure what this is
this is about in case of Israel let me
just say Israel absorbed 1 million
Russian Jews some of whom were not
Jewish hahaha right
nobody cares they get national office ok
but who does not get naturalized there
are not quite a few migrant workers from
Central American countries there are
some Ethiopian Jews who come to over the
years and there is also a significant
Africans from Sudan and other countries
are knocking on Israel's doors I think
here is also very clearly racist policy
white Israel promising that is being
conducted by this government because
nobody everybody quite a few people know
you know and I'm ok I won't
you know everybody to be naturalized
than to have citizenship because it's a
good thing but the ultimate in guiding
in it and gravity is not Jung you know
it's of course against Palestinians in
the first
but it's also against a lot of you know
around people they they don't talk so
where does this leave us you know that
just sort of my second point and I'll be
I'll be I think my third eye I just want
I just I can't accept that
this is also one political theory does
this is good this is what we do but it's
not only what we do in other words the
situated predict that we talk about at
the end of the day is going to have to
give some just think you re an argument
and not simply look at the stories of
what is available but you know I mean I
just don't agree with Walser's
methodology or political philosophy and
I would say that I think that actually
you are much more principled liberal
Democrats or whatever the well I don't
really disagree with anything that you
say it's not my argument that stories of
people hood are the better stories of
people that are sufficient to defeat all
the dangers of pathological forms of
populism it is my argument that they're
necessary and I think you conceded that
when you began by saying well if I were
running for office of course I would
tell a story because you do need to do
that and so I guess my question for you
on that point is look I don't deny that
there's racism in Israel I don't deny
that there is some deep opposition to a
variety of immigrants in an effort to
have their cake you need it to in
Denmark a country I have been to a few
times the but what I'd like to hear more
is okay I agree these stories of people
hood are not sufficient I think they're
necessary you may disagree with that but
you it's not clear that you do but what
is it at
else is it that you want me to say or
other or us to do to deal with this
racism in this opposition and I
certainly give you a chance to answer
that I will just say briefly on the
Walzer point that you'll have noticed
that while I do think as a sociological
matter our moral reasoning begins with
understandings we find in our
communities around us
I don't assert that that's all that we
rely on I say that it can lead to forms
of reasoning to find justifications that
can end up clarifying and altering those
commitments to some degree so I don't
really dispute that but I do want to
make the point that in creating
effective stories of people hood not
doing all forms of political theory but
at creating effective stories of people
you have to begin with where they are
except the case of the case of Israel is
really not about that it's sweet
generous but the case of Denmark I think
in most European instances well I agree
entirely and it's just in what was
already in over long I lecture today I
didn't spell out but all the stories of
people who should include economic and
political power themes and policies and
proposals you're absolutely right yeah
the slightly hot question that relates
to past dependents and stories of people
hood and specifically sort of as I was
listening to these examples and maybe
the risk of previewing tomorrow of
thinking about the American case a bit I
was struck by the role of the sort of
this is not who we are
as a way to push back on the service
populace of nationalism etc versus I'm
wondering why the phrase wouldn't be
something like this is not what we
should be and my question about that is
you mentioned that there's sort of
existing stories that maybe have to be
dealt with and so I've just sort of
reconciling a puzzle in my mind it's the
reason why in your you may be the key
rhetorical move for a story is this is
not who we are is because even maybe if
it's not true well you know yes for
example this country we have a lot of
problems that are definitely who we are
but is it is it that in order to make
them more convincing you think it has to
be you have to hold up the ideal of this
is what we're meant to be or something
like that I'm just curious about how
that phrase might sort of implicitly
concede a sort of path dependence with
stories well it's a good question I
actually am not comfortable
intellectually with this phrase this is
not who we are I'm not comfortable with
it because I think on the one hand it
suggests some kind of unchanging
essentialist identity for us and I don't
believe in such identities I believe to
a significant measure at least all our
identities are partly constructed chosen
contingent I mean not from nothing there
are things that are possible and things
that are not possible in the identities
we can craft for ourselves but there's I
don't like the essentialist language but
the the flipside of that is that the
identities that we do craft for
ourselves are in a significant measure
who we are they may not be unchanging
natural essentialist they may be things
we constructed but we did make ourselves
who we are and it is part of the process
of
making ourselves who we want to be by
saying we've decided this is who we are
so that's how I reconcile myself to it
although really I think of the stories
as stories of who we want to be and who
we think we should be just as you put it
I am nonetheless persuaded by an
abundant abundance of empirical evidence
that it's more effective politically to
say this is who we are
because people do actually have an
attraction for reasons we could discuss
to essentialist conceptions of their
identities well this is um a question
that returns me to debate I long had
with my thesis supervisor Judith Sklar
who saw the task of liberal political
theory as to prevent harms putting
cruelty first prevent bad things from
happening and was very wary of advancing
any strong or specific vision of the
good towards which we were tending
because she thought those could easily
be become tyrannical in one way or
another and in my younger days I
disagreed with her more than I do now
although I still have some disagreement
the I have accepted that it's often just
more imperative to combat cruelty and
brutality and atrocities than it is to
persuade people to adopt any shared
vision of what's good in life and
particularly at this moment with these
kinds of pathological populism
the engaging people and persuading them
not to do terrible things seems to me
the prime objective if you will at the
same time I continue to think that we
have that judgment because we have some
kind of notion of what a better society
and better world leading to human
fulfillment realization of human dignity
and other values would be like and the
argument that we're better if we're
adopting more inclusive and egalitarian
stories of people hood and moving toward
a world of greater accommodation in
helping people pursue diverse ways of
life in satisfying fashion that
represents a vision of a better society
that does animate the concern to prevent
various kinds of
cruelties and evils in the world but as
I tried to say in a fairly light-hearted
but unfortunately entirely sincere
fashion the the particular vision of a
Star Trek future which is a certain
vision of realization of the human good
I don't really think I can preach that
everyone has to accept and embrace that
I do think that there is an overlap
amongst many visions of the good life in
which moving in as a good narrative
meant to rope in people who are bought
into another narrative or activate
people who maybe have a body to any
narrative before oh yeah well ultimately
I think they can and they have a
potential to play a very positive role
in our sometimes playing a very positive
role from my normative point of view
they can also contribute to what I
talked about yesterday is a cacophony of
competing stories where they're
challenging national narratives in ways
that lead nationalists to push back and
so they can play a negative role in
contributing to a sense of fragmentation
that can make these strong senses of
national identity appealing but
ultimately I think we need to work
toward a world in which we accept the
legitimacy of membership in multiple
communities none of which can claim
absolute sovereignty only partial
authority over certain aspects of our
lives and all of which recognize an
obligation to cooperate as flexibly and
peacefully with other communities when
they come into conflict as possible and
the kind of stories you're talking about
challenging strong nationalist
narratives can play a role
in building support for that kind of
world my book stories and people that I
call it a world of moderate political
people's that don't claim absolute
sovereignty and that accept a lot of
overlapping memberships and
interconnection that's a controversial
ideal but is a normative ideal I defend
and so from my point of view those
stories are often beneficial I was by
your example of India and I kind of
thought of my native country do you
think mister advanced Turkish way to
return democracy is also you know when
you look at it you know from the Indian
perspective you could count a couple of
things that also applies to Turkey which
I don't think is a good example but
what's your opinion on that
well I don't have a settled opinion
because I don't know enough I did quote
my co-author marauder group janar who is
Turkish and is a she was a graduate
student at Penn and I was on our
dissertation committee we co-wrote an
article together and she's in Turkey now
and teaching and I can tell you that she
doesn't see a lot of hope for really
real accommodation of diversity in the
current political context like many
Turkish academics she's looking to get
out and of course I rely on her on
guidance for the circumstances in Turkey
nonetheless the article we wrote
together does have a discussion of
Turkey which indicates that there are
conflicting traditions there that can be
used to bill
different senses certainly there's a a
sense of Turkey as a republic and except
or under Ataturk a secular republic that
boasted of a success in bringing
different communities into the Turkish
Republic in having them flourish
although with the heavy emphasis on
assimilating to being Turkish so I see
some elements there that might be things
you can build on but how robust they are
and actually how you would craft them
right now into an effective political
story that goes beyond what I can say
it's there we have potentially there in
populations there are graphically
different demands for what qualifies as
a good story and what yeah so your
thoughts on where is the balance between
how much can be the story that we like
to the people who may be specifically
feel very uncomfortable with these
multiple affiliations and loyalties and
these multiple central stories who
actually demand one story and one
loyalty and that's a central problem and
obviously that's a tremendous challenge
and one reason I'm pushing the stories
of people hood analysis is not because I
think that if we just get the right
story we win everything there's much
more to it and certainly we need
policies responding to persons economic
and social concerns at the same time I
think that we're not doing a very good
job of telling persuasive stories now I
think David reaches write about that and
that doing so takes work it you have to
look seriously at the people that you're
saying have just a single absolutist
story and get to understand them and
their experiences and perspectives more
fully my mild optimism in this regard is
that people are more complicated than
the portrait that they're just purely
dogmatic intolerant one story people
portrays them as being and that you may
be able to find elements of things that
they care about and identify with to
build on but you can't do it if you just
write them off as you know racist bigots
or blind nationalists and so I think we
need to do more work to understand where
those people are coming from and where
we can find common ground with them on
some points with the recognition that
yeah there's some people that you're
just not going to be able to persuade
but in politics you never persuade
everybody and you can still get some
good things done if you build coalitions
that are broad enough even if there's
always opposition
[Applause]
[Music]